pour nous tous il représente quelqu'un
dans un ami en or et donc c'est
important pour nous d'être là pour lui
c'est une foule de lycéens
d'associations et d'élus qui accueillit
thomas jeune lycéen ivoiriens à la
sortie de la gendarmerie de chine ont
ils été convoquée à la demande du
procureur avec sa famille d'accueil pour
des procédures administratives
concernant sa demande d'adoption par
sylvie et alain déjà ses parents de
coeur depuis 14 mois prouve à une
personne qu'on aime c'est difficile et
mon père il est sèche peut pas lui dit
je t'aime parce que ce mot ce mot est
juste trop petit pour moi seulement
injuste trop petit de corps à mes frères
mes soeurs à ma mère à mon père à tous
les amis à tous et 10 sien je vous aime
et vraiment merci des gars plus soutien
merci beaucoup
cette convocation la gendarmerie était
une crainte pour thomas comme pour sa
famille car il ne possède pas encore de
titre de séjour
en fait il a 20 ans mais nous on s'est
jamais posé la question c'est une
rencontre
humaine et on la considérait comme notre
fils on a tout fait comme pour les
nôtres est effectivement peut-être on a
été maladroite pour les pour les
documents mais on n'y connaît rien il
sera convoqué vendredi en préfecture
pour faire le point sur son dossier et
pour l'obtention d'une éventuelle des
titres de séjour voilà donc il ya des
procédures à suivre il faut les suivre
malheureusement je regrette que certains
se sont accaparés le sujet en donnant
des fausses informations qui ont été
relayés or c'est bien qu'on ait tous ces
jeunes ici parce que on s'aperçoit qu'il
est bien intégrée dans la population
malheureusement certains font de la
récupération ce qu'ils on ne peut que
regretter beaucoup d'espoir et de
solidarité aujourd'hui au tour de thomas
déjà adopté par la famille des chinonais
[Applaudissements]